bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur Public
Sénat 440000 enfants ont basculé dans la
pauvreté entre 2008 et 2012 c'est le
constat alarmant dressé par l'Inspection
générale des affaires sociales Ligas
dans son rapport publié en janvier
dernier en cause et bien une dégradation
de la situation des familles dans
lesquells vivent ces enfants des
familles souvent monoparentales
aujourd'hui la commission des affaires
sociales du Sénat a décidé d'auditionner
les auteurs de ce rapport parmi eux et
bien Christine abrossimov et François
cherrek il les auditionne et bien sur
leur constat sur l'état de la pauvreté
en France mais surtout sur les pistes
pour endiguer ce fléo parmi les thèmes
abordés l'accès au droit l'accès à
l'emploi à l'hébergement au logement ou
encore la santé et puis les auteurs
devraient insister sur un constat les
conseils généraux depuis l'annonce de la
réforme territoriale ont tendance à se
désengager peu à peu de la lutte contre
la pauvreté un constat qui devrait faire
mouche parmi les sénateurs tout de suite
direction la salle médic pour votre
audition nous accueillons maintenant
Monsieur François CHC et Madame
abrossimov qui sont
auteurs du récent rapport d'évaluation
de de Ligas sur la mise en œuvre du plan
pauvreté et merci d'avoir donc accepté
notre invitation je voudrais commencer
par quelques chiffres pour poser les
termes de notre débat notre pays
consacre près de 40 % 40 % de sa
richesse nationale aux dépenses sociales
notre système social et fiscal est
fortement redistributif on estimait en
2012 que cette redistribution permettait
de réduire de 11 points le taux de
pauvreté des personnes vivantes au sein
d'un ménage avec enfants et de 18 points
celui des familles
monoparentales pour
autant la pauvreté c'est-à-dire le fait
de vivre avec moins de 60 % du revenu
médien soit 987 €
mensuel concerne dans notre pays 8500000
personnes soit près de 14 % de la
population derrière une stagnation
relative du taux global de pauvreté
malgré la crise apparaît une mon
inquiétante du taux de pauvreté des
enfants de moins de 18 ans il m'a paru
donc intéressant pour notre commission
de pouvoir faire le point sur la mise en
œuvre de plan de lutte contre la
pauvreté et pour l'inclusion sociale
lancé il y a 2 ans par le prés par les
représentants de liigas qui ont été
chargés d'en effectuer l'évaluation ce
plan comprenait 69 mesures dans le dans
des domaines très différents certaines
ont déjà fait l'objet de mesures
législatives et le gouvernement a
annoncé son atttention de présenter en
2015 un texte sur les sur la question du
RSA activité de la prime pour l'emploi
en débat depuis plusieurs années je vais
maintenant laisser la parole à nos
invités pour un exposé introductif ils
répondront ensuite à vos questions alors
je voudrais aussi vous dire que Monsieur
CHK et Madame abrosimov sont de ce
côté-ci et excusez-nous mais vous avez
les sénateurs derrière
vous c'est parce que en fait j'aurais
souhaité que vous puissiez être de ce
côté-ci mais on a un problème de caméra
puis vous avez un problème d'ordinateur
et de projection qui doit se faire pour
l'ensemble de nos collègues ce qui fait
que c'est un petit peu compliqué pour
vous de voir ensuite les gens qui vont
vous poser des questions mais moi je les
vois et vous inquiétez pas j'en raterai
aucun
merci oui merci monsieur le Président
euh et merci euh Mesdames et Messieurs
les sénatrices et les sénateurs pour
cette invitation
euh je on va vous présenter donc le les
éléments principaux du deuxème rapport
euh que l'on a fait alors l'année
dernière je l'ai fait avec un autre
collègue cette année avec Christina
brossimov euh le le Premier ministre
monsieur HRO quand il a mis en place ce
plan de lutte contre la pauvreté a voulu
euh qui a un rapport IGAS euh annuel euh
pour donner de la visibilité sur la mise
en œuvre du plan et c'était une façon
aussi de de donner de la clarté avec le
en particulier monde associatif qui
voulait avoir un suivi précis du du plan
normalement dans dans la démarche euh le
le rapport que nous avons remis au
Premier ministre il y a maintenant 10
jours une grosse semaine doivent être
suivi euh d'une réunion du Premier
ministre avec les différents partenaires
en particulier le Comité national de
lutte contre l'exclusion et il doit euh
faire une adaptation du plan euh annuel
avait fait monsieur héros l'année
dernière monsieur Vals nous annoncé
qu'on lui a mis le le plan qui qui
ferait cette adaptation prochainement
euh donc là vous avez les grands
éléments je vais passer assez vite sur
certains points pour pouvoir avoir plus
de temps je essayer de le faire en en 20
minutes maximum en particulier sur des
éléments législatifs vous avez de toute
façon t tous les éléments qu'on vous a
fourni sur sur ce qu'on va va dire de
toute façon déjà préciser le cadre de la
mission l'année dernière j'avais eu avec
le collègue qui travaill avec moi une
une mission d'animation territoriale
c'est-àdire que le plan avait été mis en
place et j'avais organisé des réunions
dans toutes les grandes régions dans
toutes les régions même parfois
plusieurs par région avec les conseils
généraux avec les les collectivités
territoriales les administrations les
travailleurs sociaux pour présenter le
plan on avait rencontré 6000 personnes
euh pour lancer la la dynamique c'est
quelque chose qui avait bien marché
cette année cette démarche
territorialisation ne a pas été confiée
été confié norm comme c'est normal à la
direction générale de la cohésion
sociale euh mais bon bon ce changement
je dirais de de rythme a provoqué un
petit retard dans dans l'animation
territoriale la circulaire qui
expliquait au préfet de la façon dont il
fait mettre en œuvre le plan est parti
au mois de de juillet 2014 pour l'année
2014 cétait un peu tard donc comment c
mettre en œuvre en septembre donc on a
com on regrette là dans dans la
dynamique c'est ce qu'on avait mis en
place l'année dernière a eu un petit
loup cette année euh alors vous avez les
SEP thèmes on a divisé le plan en SEP
thèmes vais revenir point par point qui
sont les les thèmes principaux des 69
mesures que vous avez cité et que vous
avez présenté d'une façon juste donc ça
me permet d'aller un peu plus vite mais
dans ces 69 mesures on en a retenu
particulièrement 19 dans notre rapport
sur les grands grands thèmes je
reviendrai dessus mais mais vous voyez
les éléments essentiels qui font débat
rendez-vous des droit c'est l'accès au
droit parce que une des parties du plan
c'est d'améliorer l'accès au droit euh
le dossier simplifié je vaisevenenir
là-dessus que que le gouvernement
voulait simplifier qui arrive pas à
simplifier justement RS activité prime
pour l'emploi vous avez fait allusion
ensuite sur travail emploi c'était la
nouveauté garantie jeune je reviendrai
par c'est un élément nouveau je dirais
dans dans la démarche la réforme de de
l'insertion par l'activité économique
hébergement logement je passe très vite
mais ça fait partie d'un des éléments
centraux et les plus problématiques dans
la mise en œuvre du plan c'est pas
nouveau euh c'est pas nouveau la santé
il y avait pas grand-chose sur la santé
dans dans dans le rapport donc beaucoup
de choses sont sont maintenant renvoyés
à la fameuse loi qui est qui qui fait
débat d'ailleurs pas qu'avec les
professionnels de santé euh donc il y
avait tout ce qui était généralisation
complémentaire de santé et et et on
avait retenu l'année dernière le
problème de la santé mentale la
précarité hein on avait retenu ça comme
priorité famille
enfance là c'est un débat qui est
redevenu d'actuel ité c'est celui de
l'accueil des des petits enfants dans
les structures collectives en
particulier des familles pauvres
inclusion bancaire et la gouvernance là
aussi débat qui qui est maintenant
débattu dans la loi avec des des
expérimentations mais je je reviendrai
mais un élément important qui était
l'Organisation des États généraux du
travail social euh donc ça c'estutre
calendrier je passe vite on vous amis et
vous pourrez la voir c'est toutes les
lois références qui euh alors qui qui
proviennent plus ou moins je dirais de
du plan parce que le plan a été mis en
place début 2013 donc la loi du janvier
sur le logement donc était fait je
dirais avant mais en même temps il y a
tout un arsenal législatif qui on
accompagné la mise en place de ce plan
que ce soit pour le logement pour
l'inclusion bancaire pour toutes les
lois de financement évidemment de la
sécurité social qui reprennent certaines
parfois des mesures sur la sur le la
consommation avec ce fameux registre
national de la consommation qui a été
déclaré anticonstitutionnel donc qui qui
amène un vide là sur sur le plan tout ce
qui est formation professionnel la loi
àure évidemment avec tout ce qui est la
prévention des expulsions euh certaines
de ces mesures qui seront pas mis en en
œuvre mais qui sont dans la loi euh donc
la loi allure on en a tout tout un
paquet
euh la loi sur égalité entre les hommes
et les femmes en particulier sur le fait
sur les impayés de pension alimentaire
he qui rentrent directement dans le dans
le problématique de la pauvreté bon loi
de finance je reviens pas c'est des
éléments évidents et puis des lois qui
sont en cours et qui vont inévitablement
impacter le le plan qui est tout ce qui
est sur la transition énergétique avec
l'échec énergie hein euh le projet de
loi de réforme de l'asile même s'il est
pas directement dans le plan mais on
voit que le problème d'hébergement est
impacté par le problème des demandeurs
d'asile et puis le projet loi de santé
en particulier c'est la santé mentale
voilà euh donc on on a tenu à faire c
ces élémentsl alors notre analyse
globale puis je reviendrai paquet par
paquet plus rapidement c'est que
globalement le gouvernement il a plutôt
respecté sa feuille de route notre
objectif nous notre notre responsabilité
c'est c'est de contrôler la feuille de
route du gouvernement et et après c'est
le monde associatif qui dit cette
feuille de route est suffisante ou pas
suffisante nous c'est pas notre notre
objet il est plutôt fidèle à la feuille
de route qui s'est donné avec quelques
je dirais quelques écarts je vais les
citer en particulier la revaloris des
minimas sociaux qui n'avait pas été fait
au-delà de l'inflation depuis pas mal de
temps RSA
ASPA les tout ce qui est pour les
familles les familles
pauvres les grandes mesures ont été
déployées rendez-vous des droits je
reviendrai dessus la garantie jeune j'en
reparlerai aussi financement par
l'activité économique ça c'est c'est
depuis le mois de juillet c'est c'est
une loi qui est qui a été votée qui a
mis en place
euh après tout ce qui est règlement et
sortie et puis l'année dernière on avait
fait une vraie critique sur la
visibilité du plan la critique existe
toujours parce que le choix du
gouvernement c'est de pas faire de loi
comme il y a ça avait été le cas
d'autrefis de loi sur ce sujet-là mais
différentes lois vous avez vu donc
globalement il y a un problème de
visibilité de ce plan qui est plutôt
intéressant mais qui globalement est est
pas assez porté politiquement même si
cette année les choses sont un peu plus
claires pour pour le grand public alors
des retards cependant
hein je l'ai dit des retards dans la
mobilisation territoriale je l'ai dit en
introduction ça c'est c'est une des
critiques dans la gouvernance il y a
plusieurs raisons je l'ai dit hein le
retard dans les circulaires qui devaient
engager le travail préfectoraux le débat
sur la place des départements qui a
inévitablement freiné la dynamique
départementale en début d'année les les
les conseils généraux sont sont dit bon
est-ce qu'on y va est-ce qu'on y va pas
je on n pas de commentaire à faire sur
le sur le fond mais nous on a constaté
que ça avait ça avait freiné je dirais
l'engagement de de l'Assemblée des
départements de France dans dans les
éléments où ils
étaient co je dirais coanimateur sur ce
sujet-là et puis on parle beaucoup on
passe on passe beaucoup par
diagnosticque donc il y a le temps des
diagnostics qui sont à partager à faire
et qui sont longs je pense en
particulier sur ce qu'on appelle 360°gr
au niveau des territoires c'est c'est
sur l'hébergement le logement il faut
effectivement du temps pour le mettre en
place euh on a certains chantiers qui
étaient importants qui qui sont en
attente qui sont modifiés les États
généraux du travail social c'était un
élément qui était très attendu dans le
dans le plan alors c'est un plan lutte
contre la pauvreté pour l'insertion
sociale donc l'inclusion sociale pardon
donc il y avait la réflexion qu'est-ce
qu'on attend du travail social et
derrière et pendant c'est la raison pour
laquelle c'est un peu compliqué il y a
les revendications des professionnels
sur la revalorisation de leur métier
donc tout ça entre le contenu du travail
social et l'évolution des professions
bon inévitablement vous savez très bien
que c'est pas toujours simple et puis
derrière les éléments de financement il
y a un retard sur les états généraux le
dossier simplifié l'ambition du de de la
ministre à l'époque c'était madame
Carlotti c'était de dire on essaie de
mettre 6 se prestations dans un dossier
unique pour éviter qu'il a 6 se demandes
hein et quand ils sont passés je dirais
à l'acte de la création de ce dossier if
ben il ilst ils ont pas fait moins de 30
pages ils ont pas fait moins de 30 pages
parce que on peut pas faire deux
demandes pour deux prestations
différentes dans un dossier unique si
les les les bases ressources des
différentes prestations sont pas les
mêmes donc au bout d'un moment faute de
simplification de nos systèmes sociaux
c'estàd essayer de mettre nos
prestations sociales sur des ressources
identiques mais on peut pas simplifier
voilà euh donc du coup ce dossier
simplifié est abandonné et il va être
remplacé par un simulateur des droits
c'est-à-dire au lieu de simplifier le
dossier on va simplifier la connaissance
des choses par les personnes donc donc
ça c'estété testé avec le le
8e collège du Séné he qui est la partie
des des personnes en situation de
pauvreté qui l'ont testé c'est de faire
qu'il puissent rentrer leur donné et
qu'on leur donne leur droit après hein
mais c'est pas le dossier simplifié donc
là il y a il y a pour nous une déception
mais c'est un sujet beaucoup plus lourd
et puis les points conseil budget qui
devaient être mis en place pour aider
les personnes en situation de son
endettement et là ça traîne parce que
entre la Banque de France entre les
banques entre les administrations euh on
a quelque chose de très lourd pour faire
quelque chose de simple voilà euh alors
sur les logements sociaux euh c'est
d'autres critiques mais là vous êtes on
est en plein débat sur euh euh
l'hébergement et le logement hein euh
donc là je reviendrai là-dessus c'est un
des éléments de de critique et puis euh
il nous semble qu'il euh la création des
places de crèche en train de se faire
mais il était prévu qu'il ait une forme
de de d'accès facilité pour les familles
pauvres et et il a fallu qu'on rappelle
cet élément là dans ce rapport pour
qu'enfin on ait un plan qui lie accueil
des enfants pauvres dans les places de
crèche pour faciliter l'accès à l'emploi
de leurs parents hein et monsieur
resamen a présenté son plan pour le
chômeur de longue durée et a repris
cette cette proposition et on est plutôt
satisfait parce que c'est quand même un
élément cruciale comment elle est un
entretien d'embauche on peut pas faire
garder ses enfants et c'est le problème
des familles monoparentales en
particulier voilà et puis derrière on
avait de fortes attentes en matière
d'insertion et d'emploi alors est-ce que
le plan de Monsieur remsen répond à ces
attentes là en tout cas le plan existe
maintenant il existait pas au moment
qu'on l'a fait dans dans le rapport
alors on a souhaité en introduction de
notre de notre rapport faire un point
sur le contexte de la pauvreté alors je
rappelle que les les documents que l'on
a sont les documents de 2012 hein
c'est-à-dire c'est les les statistiques
initié de 2012 donc le le plan se met en
place en 2013 mais il semblait important
quand même de faire un focus important
vous parliez de système social c'est
vrai que on a un amortisseur social très
fort on l'a vu pendant la crise en 2008
he j'était dans d'autres fonctions et on
a pu constater que quand on faisait
fonctionner ben
le le système fonctionnait très bien
vous avez pris des des chiffres pour les
familles parentales qui sont exactes
donc on a je dirais une évolution euh
assz est plate depuis quelques années du
taux de pauvreté donc on n' pas une
augmentation euh du taux de pauvreté
mais quand on regarde dans le dans
l'évolution du taux de pauvreté ceux qui
sont en dessous du seil de pauvreté sont
plus pauvres hein vous savez on calcule
le taux de pauvreté à 60 % du salaire
médien et à 50 %. on a un stagnation du
taux de pauvreté à 60 % du salaire
médien mais une augmentation à 50 %.
hein ce qui veut dire que les pauvres
euh sont pas plus nombreux mais ils sont
plus pauvres premier élément deuxème
élément on a voulu faire un focus sur la
pauvreté des des enfants en particulier
des familles pauvres euh parce que il
nous semble que c'est le sujet le le
plus lourd actuellement dans notre pays
le taux de pauvreté des enfants est
quasiment un enfant sur 5 vit dans une
famille pauvre hein euh et et ça va sur
euh un sur TR quand c'est les familles
monoparentales et puisqu'on parle
beaucoup de certains quartiers ça va
quasiment sur un sur de ou 4/ 10 donc
euh d'ailleurs on peut s'interroger ou
quand tout C politiques sociales vont
vers les mêmes populations que
globalement le taux de pauvreté baisse
pas sur ces populations il faut
s'interroger aussi de l'organisation de
ces politiques sociales et on a mis le
le focus sur cet élément là parce qu'il
nous semble c'est un élément important
qui était dans le plan et et donc on on
a souhaité qu'il qu' a un plan
spécifique pour pour ces familles là je
je je reviendrai et puis dernier élément
qu'on a soulevé bah l'opinion se durcit
vis-à-vis de de
laassistana le le créog qui fait des
enquêtes depuis 35 ans constate que le
taux d'acceptabilité de la population de
de notre système social est le plus bas
depuis 35 ans hein ce qui veut pas dire
que les Français sont pas généreux parce
que le niveau de de de d'aide est
important aussi euh mais les Français
privilégient les services aux
prestations donc ça c'est un élément qui
qui doit aussi être interrogé euh voilà
alors les SEP thèmes je vais aller très
vite sur les SEP thèmes maintenant pour
pouvoir des éléments du débat sur
l'accès au droit j'ai dit revalorisation
des minimas sociaux j'en parle pas les
100000 rendez-vous des droits c'est la
knaf qui les organise donc c'est on on
on convoque des personnes euh pour leur
expliquer leur droit en particulier dans
les période de rupture en cas de divorce
en cas de décès euh de quelqu'un d'un
des parents on les convoque pour leur
expliquer leur droit donc ça s'est mis
en place et ça va bien
euh les points de critiques c'est le
dossier simplifié je je vous en ai parlé
euh euh les points de vigilance euh nous
on fait une une alerte sur la fusion de
la de r activité la prime pour l'emploi
c'est une bonne chose hein parce queil
il faut le faire donc le gouvernement a
décidé de le faire pour le 1er janvier
2016 donc je pense que le projet de loi
doit être prêt avant l'été mais il y a
deux façons de le faire ou créer une
prime d'activité qui est une prime
d'activité familiarisée et on revient
dans le problème du RSA activité qui est
une prime d'activité familiarisée où on
fait une prime d'activité lié à l'emploi
donc on favorise la rémunération du
travail c'était le débat qui était fait
dans la création du R ça le débat
revient nous on privilégie une prime
d'activité dissocié de d'une prime
familiarisée donc le gouvernement doit
faire le choix je sais pas quel choix il
va faire parce que si on veut valoriser
le travail on valorise le travail si on
veut valoriser le la famille on fait la
famille dans ce moment-là c'est une
prestation familiale ou une prestation
de travail il faut faire le choix prime
pour l'emploi a été tourné vers le
travail et reste activité tourné vers la
famille si on fait la fusion il faut
choisir voilà deuxième élément euh
l'APRE qui était l'accompagnement des
personnes en recherche d'emploi était
supprimé au niveau financement donc là
il y a il y a un côté négatif et puis
l'aide alimentaire ça marche bien l'aide
alimentaire les moyens sont là mais on
voudrait que l'aide alimentaire soit
soit mieux organisé
avec je dirais les les parcours sociaux
c'est bien d'aider les gens pour l'aide
alimentaire mais c'est bien les aider
pour qu'ils reviennent pas donc il y a
le problème de l'accompagnement derrière
là-dessus euh alors l'accès à l'emploi
la garantie jeune je vous rappelle c'est
pour les ce qu'on appelle Inini ni en
emploi ni en formation les jeunes les
plus éloignés de l'emploi les mettre
dans un parcours de formation
d'accompagnement très rigide ce parcours
très exigeant pour les jeunes surtout au
départ et et pour les amener à la
formation ou à l'emploi l'objectif 2014
est en échange le jeune signe un
contrat un revenu d'activité du niveau
du RSA socle et il lui est supprimé si
il accepte pas ou il respecte pas le
parcours donc l'objectif était 10000
cette année on arrivé à 8000 parce que
c'est une nouvelle pratique et c'est pas
été facile de mettre ça en œuvre il faut
all les chercher les jeunes donc ça
c'est et maintenant ça marche bien le
gouvernement accélère la cadence au lieu
de 30000 cette année ce sera 50000 et
100000 l'année d'après euh deuxième
élément qui sont positifs les les
conventions d'accompagnement des
personnes c'est les les accords qui sont
passés entre département et Pôle emploi
sur l'accompagnement des personnes les
plus éloignées de l'emploi il y a une
expérimententation qui é franche compté
qui commence à
généraliser très bien parce que le
Conseil général met des travailleurs
sociaux à disposition le Pôle Emploi met
des des des salariés pô l'emploi à
disposition pour qu'ils travaill
ensemble pour que la personne quand elle
rentre à Pô emploi et un suivi social et
quand qu'elle rentre au par le conseil
général et un suivi pour l'emploi pour
éviter d'avoir deux guichets quoi donc
ça c'est quelque chose d'important et
puis bon tout ce qui est validation des
des niveaux mais je je passe à assez
vite là-dessus il y a pas eu de travail
sur la mobilité des travailleurs
modestes c'est un regret euh et puis il
y avait le problème de l'accès à la
formation en particulier des euh des
travailleurs handicapés c'est le jour
aujourd'hui euh alors on a fait un
rapport intermédiaire hein euh avec ma
collègue sur les travailleurs handicapés
on a fait des des propositions sur ce
sujet-là qui sont malheureusement pas
encore repris là-dessus et puis on veut
être attentif à au financement de
l'insertion par l'activité économique
euh en en en faisant en sorte que ça
soit bien ciblé vers les personnes qui
ont le plus besoin hébergement logement
pour résumer ce sujet là pour pas être
trop long il y a l'hébergement le
gouvernement fait son travail en terme
de création de place d'hébergement
d'urgence et
de accueil des demandeurs d'asile mais
on a un flux important des demandeurs
qui fait que plus on on en crée la
demande est toujours la même premier
élément deuxème élément on a tous les
demandeurs d'asile déboutés du droit
d'asile non
expulsable parce qu'ils ont des enfants
nés dans le pays et autres donc qui
restent sur le territoire national et ça
c'est un constat qui ont pas accès au
logement social et qui occupe toutes ces
fameuses unités d'hôtelière hôtelière
dont on a parlé récemment ce qui fait
que ces personnes-là sont à l'hôtel ça
coûte très très cher sans accompagnement
social et ça bloque les centres
d'hébergement pour les personnes
nouvellement accueillies là-dessus même
s'il y a de nouvelles places de pour les
demandeurs d'asile qui sont créés donc
sur ce sujet là on a on demande un un
plan d'urgence sur ce sujet-là la
ministre l'a annoncé il y a quelques
jours euh pour faire euh baisser le
nombre de nuités hôtelières et de passer
par de l'intermédiation locative
c'est-à-dire que les associations
mettent des appartements à disposition
public ou privé d'ailleurs pour que ces
personnes-là soient un appartement avec
un suivi social pour éviter cette
situation qui qui est très coûteuse d'un
côté mais que au niveau sanitaire euh au
niveau euh alimentation pose des vrais
problèmes pour les enfants en
particulier qui qui sont logés dans ces
dans ces situations là donc ça on a un
appel sur ce point-là et puis l'autre
point critique c'est la création de
logements sociaux où on est
éternellement en retard sur les
objectifs dans notre pays pour en
particulier des questions de Frontier
mais vous connaissez les les éléments
donc dans la loi allure il y a certains
éléments qui qui permettent d'avancer
sur ce sujet-là de regret sur la loi
allure l'abandonn l'abandon de la
garantie universelle des loyers et puis
les fameux observatoires des loyers qui
seront que de ties expérimental sur sur
Paris moi je juge pas on juge pas sur le
fond c'est dans la loi et et c'est pas
mis en œuvre
euh donc les point de vigilance je je je
l'ai dit les diagnostics 360° j'en ai
parlé c'est ce que les préfectures do
doivent faire et puis il y a le problème
de l'effectivité de de la du droit au
logement opposable alors deux chiffres
qui sont assez difffiants depuis la
création de cette loi 500000 demandes
450000 personnes qui sont relogées donc
c'est plus plutôt positif 50000 en
attente de relogement 40000 en
île-de-fance donc vous avez là la carte
je dirais des difficultés du logement
donc c'est c'est très
île- de- France ronalp et bougeedrone
mais et puis un petit peu dans le Nord
pas decala on en trouve un peu dans
toutes les régions mais mais c'est
vraiment un sujet qui est très compliqué
à à traiter mais là on la loi la loi
àure fait des propositions dans ce
sens-là la santé donc je reviens pas sur
les les prestation il y a une prestation
qui était qui était intéressante c'était
l'augmentation du euh du plafond pour
avoir accès la CMUC et la CMU de 7 % qui
a fait rentrer plus de 500000 personnes
dans le dispositif donc ça ça a marché
avec les les différents décrets sur les
sur les paniers de soins les points de
vigilance et la loi santé le lien entre
le sanitaire le social maladie mentale
l'accès au soins l'accès au social est
un élément important et la
généralisation des des complémentaires
santé
euh le taux de nos recours important on
reste sur un problème de nos recours à
CMUC et à CS c'est la raison pour
laquelle on fait une proposition elle a
été faite plusieurs fois elle a été
faite dans le rapport de Madame
archambau sur l'accès aux soins pour les
personnes en situation de pauvreté c'est
l'automaticité pour les personnes que le
RSA de la CMUC euh bon ça ça ça ça
bloque mais on refait cette proposition
là là-dessus euh famille enfance je
reviens pas sur les prestations sociales
l'élément essentiel c'est il me semble
là-dessus c'est les les accueils
collectifs et les accès aux crèches j'en
ai parlé tout à l'heure et la la
proposition que l'on fait et puis une
attention particulière sur l'aide
sociale à l'enfance he en particulier
les jeunes adultes qui sortent de l'aide
sociale à l'enfance et puis les mineurs
étrangers qui qui qui qui a un des
problèmes sociaux qu'on qu'on rencontre
dans notre pays bon je vais passer sur
l'inclusion bancaire parce que je l'ai
dit c'est les points conseil budgets qui
sont les éléments essentiels pour pas
être trop long et sur la gouvernance là
aussi je va assz V il y a il y a des
expérimentations qui sont fait dans dans
une opération qu'ils ont appelé agile
c'est les départements qui veulent
améliorer leur gouvernance ou ou ou
sortir des des textes juridiques sur la
gouvernance pour être plus fluide et
plus adapté c'est parti de quatre
départements mtosel Nord valdoise et drô
maintenant il y a une dizaine de
départements qui sont dans
l'expérimentation ça marche plutôt bien
et on se dit c'est plutôt intéressant
l'échangement sur sur le terrain plutôt
que ça soit imposé d'en haut
euh et puis bon des faiblesses
statistiques je reviens pas sur ces
éléments là c'est c'est moins
intéressant donc je je conclus hein sur
les les quatre les cinq proposition
principale que l'on fait on en fait 45
mais on en a sorti 5 le plan d'aide pour
les familles pauvres hein l'idée
derrière hein c'est dire on règlera pas
toutous les problèmes de pauvreté
uniquement par les minimas sociaux hein
c'est que les minimas sociaux sont
revalorisés mais si on veut que les
personnes sortent de la pauvreté il faut
qu'ils a un accompagnement vers l'emploi
en particulier les les mères qui sont
seuls avec leurs enfants donc pour faire
un accompagnement vers l'emploi
formation
euh accompagnement renforcé vers
l'emploi mais aussi structure collectif
pour que les enfants soient soient pris
en charge ça c'est la première
proposition deuxième je nai parlé c'est
la prime RSA activité prime pour
l'emploi donc je reviens pas là-dessus
troème proposition euh le plan d'urgence
pour l'hébergement d'urgence et ça on
est en route là-dessus l'accès
automatique à la CMUC et la CS euh pour
les personnes l'accès automatique pour
les personnes qu' on le RSA s musé et
puis qu'on ait un calendrier ferme et
définitif des États généraux du travail
social parce que c'est une demande forte
des des professionnels mais aussi des
intervenants sociaux je vous remercie je
suis arrivve au bout merci beaucoup
monsieur CHK je vais de suite passer la
parole au rapporteur général monsieur
vaninberg qui a quelques questions à
vous poser ensuite il y a pas mal de
collègues qui se sont inscrits levez les
mains comme il faut qu'on vous voit en
plus madame
Cohen madame douanau monsieur mouiller
madame geditelli madame archimbaau
madame
Génisson Monsieur
foruissier Madame pancassia oui c'est
noté ah bon c'est noté c'est
noté ben c'est bien monsieur cadiic
monsieur van Renberg a la parole bien
merci monsieur le président
monsieurinspecteur général c'est un
rapport extrêmement complet riche et je
suis bien content qu'il a beaucoup
d'intervenants parce que je ne peux pas
embrasser tous les sujets que vous avez
abordés qui sont tous éminemment
sensibles évidemment sur lesquelles on
pourrait effectivement prolonger
longuement le débat
euh la première recommandation du
rapport c'est la mise en place d'un plan
d'aide aux familles euh aux familles
pauvres bien sûr comprenant notamment
des accompagnements renforcés vers
l'emploi des parents quelle forme
concrète pourrait prendre ces mesures
que pensez-vous notamment des
dispositifs permettant une insertion en
entreprise du type préparation
opérationnelle à l'emploi ou proposition
des entreprises pour former directement
euh des demandeurs d'emploi voilà la
première question ensuite sur la réforme
des dispositifs de soutien à la reprise
d'activités euh PPE prime pour l'emploi
RSA quel schéma recommandez-vous de
favoriser euh vous l'avez évoqué
pour tout dire mais notre dispositif
d'aide n'est pas suffisamment incitatif
financièrement un ciblage plus important
et plus incitatif ne devrait-il pas
nécessairement aussi faire des
perdants à financement identique bien
sûr vous vous les prestations d'aide aux
familles ne sont-elles pas trop
nombreuses et trop
complexes quelle piste de lification
pourriez-vous envisager dans une logique
plus d'accès au droits plutôt que d'un
rendez-vous des
droits vous avez un peuleuré le sujet et
je crois que c'est très
important il y a une
méconnaissance de beaucoup de de
familles de personnes pauvre de leur
droit tout simplement et et la pauvreté
elle nît aussi de cela euh vous n'avez
pas chiffré non plus le plan et ni sa
mise en œuvre pensez-vous que des moyens
supplémentaires devrait être mobilisé ou
devrons-nous ou devons-nous plutôt
revoir les dispositifs et leur
efficience
et je mettrai un un point aussi sur le
logement
euh vous avez d'ailleurs souligner en
parlant du dalallo
euh les caractéristiques concernant
l'île-de-fance je crois que il est très
important effectivement
euh de de de rappeler qu'on on a on
s'est fixé un objectif et on est loin de
l'avoir atteint de 150000 logements par
an
mais je pense qu'il y a des fortes
fortes disparités suivant les régions
suivant les les les les villes euh
et je ne sais pas si vous avez dans ce
domaine des préconisations particulière
au-delà du foncier mais le foncier je
dirais presque aujourd'hui c'est devenu
un peu la tarte à la crème quoi et et
beaucoup de se cache derrière ce
problème il y a une volonté et peut-être
aussi des incitations qui permettrait
effectivement de débloquer la
situation j'ai aussi apprécié que vous
soulignnez l'abandon du Gul ici même
j'ai toujours plaidé pour la mise en
place de cette garantie
universel qui permet je rappelle
essentiellement qui favorise la
mobilité des jeunes travailleurs
notamment
et on l'a abandonné en race campagne
alors que le Sénat avait travaillé toute
commission confondue toute sensibilité
confondue pour faire une proposition
intelligente dans ce domaine je sais pas
si vous en avez eu connaissance mais je
pense qu'il serait intéressant
effectivement de la faire ressurgir
merci je je en prendre deux autres
madame
Debray monsieur le Président Monsieur je
m'adresse à vous en tant que président
de terranovva en même temps inspecteur
général des affaires sociales et aussi
en tant que secrétaire ancien secrétaire
général de la CFDT ma question va être
très courte vous avez entendu parler ce
matin de ce cas de ce boulanger qui est
à qui est dans les Landes qui se voit
contraint de fermer sa boulangerie qui
l'ouvrait depuis 3 ans et demi tous les
jours en respectant bien sûr les règles
pour les salariés puisque chaque salarié
avait 2 jours de vacances enfin de jours
pardon de de congé euh je voudrais avoir
votre avis là-dessus sachant qu'il
perdra je crois de l'ordre de 250000 €
par an de de de recette et surtout qu'il
mettra deux personnes qui en général les
personnes qui travaillent dans les
boulangeries ne sont pas forcément des
gens qui ont des moyens absolument
gigantesques de personnes au chômage or
a priori il faudrait changer certaines
choses puisque d'après ce que j'ai
regardé ce
matin le vous pouvez ouvrir la
boulangerie effectivement 7 jours par
semaine à condition que vous ne vendiez
pas de pain pendant 24 heures c'est un
petit peu gênant quand même donc je
voudrais avoir votre avis là-dessus
puisque ça concerne directement le
travail donc monsieur Cardou
oui merci monsieur le Président mais
merci au à l'orateur à l'intervenant de
ce rapport très complet sur le bilan sur
le les problèmes d'inclusion sociale et
je j'aurais tendance à dire que
l'inclusion sociale et ça sera le centre
de mon intervention passe
essentiellement par l'emploi et mon
intervention sans esprit polémique
plutôt dans une logique consensuelle
voudrais simplement vous rappeler ce que
je qualifierais les de rendez-vous
perdus ou d'occasion manqué et en
particulier tous ces textes auxquels
vous avez fait allusion dans votre
présentation pour lesquels nous avions
lancé des mises en garde et dont on se
rend compte maintenant que petit à petit
le gouvernement revient en arrière tout
simplement par pragmatisme et volonté
d'efficacité alors je les signalerai
très très succintement commençons par
l'an et la durée du travail à temps
partiel de 24 he les contrats de
génération qui ont beaucoup de mal à
décoller et ça nous l'avions signalé le
compte
pénibilité que actuellement sur lequel
le gouvernement travaille pour le rendre
Simp plus simple pour les petites
entreprises les emplois aidés où nous
avions ont souhaité qu'il soit beaucoup
plus ouvert au secteur marchand et je
voistis avec satisfaction que le
ministre du Travail a proposé de doubler
pour les porter de 50000 à 100000
l'année prochaine ce qu'on considère
encore comme insuffisant la formation
professionnelle et l'apprentissage qui
par un moment a été sacrifié et on
revient en arrière pour refinancer
l'apprentissage la formation
professionnelle avec l'usine à gaz des
listes par région qui vont être un
blocage et puis enfin la loi allure dont
on sait qu'elle G des blocages
importants dans le secteur du bâtiment
je pour mémoire vous n'avez pas signalé
un texte qui a notre sens tout au moins
une décision qui est à notre sens
importante en particulier concernant le
cumul ASPA et complément d'activité
c'est une PPL qui avait été portée par
Isabelle Debray qui était passée avec
une forte majorité au Sénat et que nous
avons eu beaucoup de mal à concrétiser
dans les faites par une décision
réglementaire par un décret qui n n'a eu
lieu que le 22 décembre 2014 et qui
n'était simplement qu'une mesure de bon
sens et de justice sociale comme quoi
nous avons eu beaucoup de mal à le
mettre en œuvre et vous ne le citez pas
dans votre dans votre présentation
c'était simplement un rappel que je
voulais faire alors à partir de tout ce
que je viens d'énumérer ne pensez-vous
pas toujours dans le sens de
l'efficacité pour l'emploi qu'il
faudrait avoir des démarches d'amont
beaucoup plus consensuel où on étudie
mieux les textes et que finalement on
évite TR ces tergiversation et ses
retour en arrière et pour conclure très
rapidement vous dire que j'ai noté dans
vos propositions dans ce qui est à venir
cette problème de fusion du RSA et de la
prime pour l'emploi qui me semble
fondamental et là je souhaite que la la
passerelle entre majorité et opposition
puisse se faire parce c'est un enjeu
fondamental et là je crois qu'on ne peut
pas se permettre de passer à
côté monsieur CHK juste une chose j'ai
15 inscrits je laisser assez vite non
c'est pas
non sur dem au questionneur de pas
mettre 10 minutes par question parce que
15 par 10 ça fait 150 minutes et vous
avez plus de temps vous pour répondre
oui d'abord je vous préciser je je peux
pas répondre à tout je reste sur le le
plan pauvreté et je suis là en tant
qu'inspecteur général des affaires
sociales j'ai pas ni en tant qu'ancien
futur je sais pas mais en tout cas je je
suis oui intéressant mais on est
toujours futur de quelque chose on est
toujours futur de quelque chose non mais
je je je je précise je précise ça parce
qu'autrement
euh non non non mais je je c'est la
vousz bien marqu le le le rapport il
était très très très bordé c'était sur
les euh sur les mesures du gouvernement
et et sur l'analyse des mesures donc
c'est pas un rapport sur le système de
formation professionnelle c'est pas un
rapport sur le logement non plus donc il
est difficile de autrement on aurait
fait 10 rapports hein et d'ailleurs euh
on on on cite dans notre rapport tous
les autres rapports IGAS qui sont plus
ou moins directement liés à ça et qui
amèent des éléments de complément alors
d'abord sur les familles pauvres euh moi
je je je répète ce que je disais
l'élément c'est de se dire on ne peut
pas il faut euh valoriser les minimas
sociaux quand ils sont insuffisants mais
j'ai envie de dire pour sortir vraiment
de de la pauvreté il faut qu'il ait des
actions de service et d'accompagnement
hein d'où cette démarche de dire c'est
le même débat que sur le handicap dans
le rapport qu'on a fait sur le handicap
on a rencontré les associations qui
voulaient que l'âge par exemple soit au
niveau du salaire minimum on dit c'est
pas possible d'abord financièrement et
puis distingue le travail à une
prestation sociale c'est un élément
important aussi et deuxièmement les
handicapés ont des problèmes d' d'accès
au droit des problèmes d'accès à la
santé des problèmes de de reste à charge
des problèmes d'accès à l'emploi c'est
sur ces sujet là qu'il faut qu'il faut
faire en sorte pour que les personnes
sortent de leur situation d'exclusion et
dehicap donc pour les fem famill pauvr
et en particulier les mamans qui vivent
seules avec leurs enfants c'est cette
démarche là et à partir de cette
démarche là un plan d'accompagnement de
formation des personnes d'accompagnement
vers l'emploi c'est ce que le ministre a
proposé alors on a on n pas travaillé
dans les détails mais comme vous dites
formation en entreprise moi je peux vous
dire je suis pas choqué que on met en
place des systèmes de formation en
alternance pour pour adultte je dire ça
marche donc il y a pas de raison et il y
a des il y a des initiatives privées en
particulier dans le domaine des services
qui sont fait par les grands chefs de
des restaurants qui font des formations
pour adultes en alternance dans des
initiative totalement privée he qui
marche très bien qui vont chercher des
personnes très en exclusion donc il y a
pas de raison de s'inpirer de ce qui
marche pour pour faire ça mais c'est
c'est l'accompagnement qui est
nécessaire RSA prime pour emploi je l'ai
dit privilégier l'activité alors il y
aura des si on privilégie un ou l'autre
il y a des perdants hein et et c'est
vrai que les les resp responsables
politiques vous les les les
parlementaires c'est vrai c'est toujours
difficile de faire de faire des
perdantes si on choisit la prestation
professionnelle donc la la valorisation
du travail il y a des perdants dans les
familles hein donc il faut qu'il ait un
système d'accompagnement provisoire pour
que ces famillesl ne comment dirais-je
le perd le moins possible sachant très
bien qu'il a un turnover dans les
familles qu'au bout de de de 4 5 ans
c'est plus les mêmes familles parce que
les gens retrouvent du travail parce que
les les familles se reconstituent donc
il faut accompagner les personnes qui
sont en situation mais il faut faire un
choix et le choix c'est plutôt
l'activité que l'on que l'on propose
euh après le plan l'a pas chiffré parce
que le gouvernement l'a pas chiffré hein
donc on l'a mis que globalement c'est
bon c'est c'est une critique des
associations depuis le début il a pas
été chiffré donc on sait en gros les ce
que ce représente les augmentations des
minimas sociaux et compagni mais le
reste non on est un peu dans dans le
flou donc ça c'est c'est un difficultés
euh je vais vite hein sur les réponses
et puis après sur sur le dalallo euh oui
il y a des disparité mais on trouve pas
normal par exemple qu'il a des qu'il a
des villes en France où il y a pas de
problème de pression sur le logement où
il y a des nulités hôtelières donc là il
y a quelque chose qui va pas dans
l'organisation du système donc pour le
moment le système alimente le système
donc au bout d'un moment il faut prendre
des décisions pour faire en sorte que
les unités hôelières dans il y a
certaines villes devraent pas y avoir du
tout euh donc donc ces élément là et et
donc comme il y a des logements
disponibles l'intermédiation avec les
les associations est quelque chose de
très simple faire là-dessus et on règle
une partie des des des problèmes et donc
c'est une question aussi de volonté de
volonté politique mais on n' pas fait un
rapport sur ce sujetl juste une
parenthèse sur les boulangers je je vais
pas aller loin là-dessus non mais moi il
me semble quand j'étais responsable
départemental que c'est des accords
entre la chambre des métiers des
boulangers et les préfets et donc il
faut aussi que les professionnels
s'adressent à leurs représentants pour
pour que le décret préfectoral soit
différent voilà donc au bout d'un moment
faire une médiatisation sur un sujet qui
peut se régler simplement
territorialement je trouve un peu un peu
bizarre voilà c'est tout après j'irai
pas plus loin sur sur ce sujet là jeai
je l'ai traité quand j'étais
syndicaliste de terrain il y a un décret
préfectoral il est accepté par la
Chambre des Métiers voilà donc il faut
s'adresser à la Chambre des
Métiers après sur le reste je pas de
commentaire monsieur
mauriiss bien monsieur le Président je
vais être bref je m'en reste au rapport
en regardant simplement la diapo qui est
devant moi et en regardant développer un
plan d'urgence d'accès à l'hébergement
et au logement je suis rapporteur du
budget justement sur ce point bien
particulier tous les ans et et lorsque
je vous entends effectivement dire que
les crédits d'hébergement continuent à
croître je crois qu'il y a un fossé
qu'il faut rectifier parce que les
crédits de 2015 sont inférieurs au
réalisés de 2013 et vous nous le dites
vous-même que il y a des problèmes à
régler
l'énuité les centres d'hébergement et
lorsqu'on reçoit les asso association
tant Maus que les autres associations il
y a un grand fossé entre le plan annoncé
en 2013 et la réalisation sur le terrain
je crois que là-dessus donc vous nous
avez dit tout à l'heure que vous étiez
rassuré par le ministre comme quoi il y
aurait des crédits complémentaires
est-ce que quel est l'information à quel
montant parce que là effectivement il y
a déjà nécessité d'abonder par une
décision modificative les crédits déjà
en 2015 j'aurais souhaité avoir votre
point de vue et puis concernant la
gouvernance il y a 11 mesures et donc
dans ces 11 mesures il y en a une qui
m'intéresse beaucoup c'est donner un
nouveau souffle au service d'information
d'accueil et d'orientation et
concrètement lorsqu'on n auditionne la
directrice de la cohésion sociale on
voit très bien que c'est un sujet qui
traîne et qui se met difficilement en
place quel est votre point de vue sur ce
point-là monsieur
gofroid monsieur le Président ce sera
rapide oui dans votre chapitre
concernant la pauvreté vous faites état
de cet accroissement de la pauvreté
notamment la pauvreté des enfants et
vous êtes passé un petit peu vite sur un
paragraphe qui moi m'intéresse beaucoup
qui est juste en fin de parcours quand
vous parlez de l'opinion des Français
qui se durcit à l'égard des personnes
pauvres euh je pense que dans les
recommandations que vous faites de
d'avoir des structures collectif crèche
école et donc un emploi stable pour les
familles monoparentales il nous faudra
nous au niveau local pouvoir expliquer
comment est-ce que est-ce que vous avez
développé cette ce comment dirais-je ce
sentiment à l'égard des personnes
pauvres qui est colporté par un certain
nombre de personnes et qui manifestement
est complètement erroné est-ce que vous
avez des pistes à nous proposer pour
faire tomber cette ce cette comment
dirais-je cette affirmation par lequel
il est plus avantageux de percevoir les
minim sociaux que de travailler avec un
bas salaire madame Cohen
oui merci j'ai trouvé euh ce propos
extrêmement intéressant et avec des
chiffres qui nous ont été donnés euh par
vous d'ailleurs monsieur le Président
quand vous rappelez que 40 % de la
richesse nationale est consacrée aux
dépenses sociales ça ça situe quand même
la la la question et puis moi aussi dans
les éléments qui ont été rapportés je
suis comme Jean-Pierre gaauefroid euh
j'ai été intéressé par cette
constatation les Français privilégie les
services aux prestations et ça me semble
intéressant d'avoir un échange là-dessus
parce que je crois qu'il y a confusion
aussi entretenu d'ailleurs par le le le
débat idéologique sur la différence
entre solidarité ass
et la deuxième chose c'est que je trouve
positif que les Français soutiennent les
services parce que moi je traduis par
soutien des services publics d'où ça
nous interroge en tant qu'élu en tant
qu'élu en tant que parlementaire mais
aussi en tant qu'élus locaux sur les
moyens qui sont de plus en
plus en baisse consacrés donc au
servicees public et notamment au service
public de proximité donc ça rentre en
contradiction avec y compris ce que vous
souhaitez euh vous euh ce que vous
pointez au niveau par exemple de
l'accueil de la petite enfance et cetera
et cetera donc là il y a une certaine
contradiction il faut avoir les moyens
de de de la politique qui est affichée
ça c'était ma première remarque deuxème
remarque vous insistez sur les femmes
seules en terme de de de pauvreté
effectivement euh les femmes donc ont
des des petits salaires pour la majorité
il y a un problème aussi au niveau des
femmes retraitées et euh je je me dis je
ne l'ai pas vu mais euh c'est quand même
aussi des intentions que gouvernemental
et ça fait longtemps que c'est dans les
textes il y a quand même un problème
d'égalité salariale qui n'est pas posé
là et on sait que ça permettrait quand
même d'améliorer un certain nombre de
choses euh la loi existe les décrets
existent mais ça ne passe pas dans la
pratique donc comment faire pour que ça
se ça se corrige enfin on est quand même
en 2015 3è réflexion c'est au niveau de
l'hébergement d'urgence et notamment là
on est sur la problématique du du du du
logement social moi je suis quand même
frappé sur la non apppplication de la
loi SRU qui fait que il y a des villes
nombreuses qui refusent de construire du
logement social et qui donc acceptent de
de payer des pénalités mais du coup les
villes qui construisent sont pénalisées
parce que il y a un espèce d'appel de de
la population qui va en direction de de
ces villes-là et donc au niveau de de
cette problématique je voudrais savoir
si y compris à la loi àure effectivement
mais si on peut pas aller plus loin pour
essayer de voir comment est-ce qu'on
peut encourager j'allais dire les mères
bâtisseur et donc faire en sorte que ils
puissent retrouver une partie du
contingent du du préfet ce qui
permettrait peut-être d'augmenter les
hébergements d'urgence et donc de
répondre à ce que vous soullignez au
niveau notamment des femmes qui sont en
situation difficile madame douanau
oui tout d'abord je voudrais remercier
cette présentation en tout cas ce
rapport d'évaluation qui a dû être
perturbé quelque peu en tout cas dans
dans dans sa mise en œuvre par la
réforme territoriale qui était en marche
et surtout la suppression des
départements qui étaient annoncés or on
sait que l'action sociale en majorité
est exercée par les départements pas
seulement hein parce que on sait bien
qu'on le partage sur les territoires
mais cependant les départements la
moitié de leurs dépenses à peu près et
acré à l'action sociale donc votre
action monsieur cherk et je vous
remercie d'ailleurs d'avoir été sur tous
les territoires ça c'est vrai que on
peut souligner votre implication vous
avez été très présent sur toutes les
régions mais vous avez quand même dû
ressentir cette espèce de
tsunami local le département remis en
cause alors que effectivement c'est sa
principale préoccupation l'action
sociale vous avez dû aussi entendre que
les travaux de cette
réforme enfin la nouvelle organisation
territoriale implique que ce seront
désormais les les régions qui
s'occuperont d'emploi quel est votre
avis sur sur la question je j'y serais
très enfin je serais très intéressé de
la
connaître qu'est-ce qui s'est passé pour
les départements en plus du fait qu'ils
étaient remis en cause c'est qu'en fait
le nombre de de bénéficiaires du RSA
mais pas seulement ont augmenté le
nombre d'enfants qui sont confiés dans
tous les départements a augmenté
également vous parlez des des femmes
seules elles sont de plus en plus
nombreuses à solliciter effectivement
les aides des départements notamment
pour les dépenses d'énergie les dépenses
de logement euh on voit mais fréquemment
maintenant et ça c'est un indice pour
tous les départements beaucoup de
dossiers où les personnes sont euh avec
des dossiers de surendettement avec
parfois une deuxème PRP de prononcé donc
euh voilà on peut on peut se dire que
que là on est on est vraiment dans la
pauvreté l'ultime pauvreté donc une
augmentation des bénéficiaires donc une
augmentation des accompagnements ce qui
fait que les départements se sont
organisés dans dans une nouvelle offre
de servicees je vais présenter dans
quelques semaines un un plan un schéma
dans mon département pour une ouvr
l'offre de service et puis en même temps
nos professionnels ont été mobilisés sur
des plan départemental d'insertion on va
présenter le pacte territorial
d'insertion euh bref on est
continuellement mobilisé sur l'écriture
de plan de pacte de schéma ce qui nous
finalement nous nous aide pas à être
fonci sur le terrain là où il faudrait
être et sans parler du plan
départemental de l'habitat qui qui
rejoint aussi vos préoccupations donc
autant dire que les départements une
hausse de leurs dépenses une hausse de
leur mobilisation et néanmoins une
baisse de leurs moyens et donc une
remise en cause
continuelle donc je vais peut-être
m'arrêter là parce que je vais laisser
la place à mes collègues j'avais dit 10
minutes monsieur
mouiller oui bonjour bonjour à tous je
vais faire rapide euh pour vous dire
d'abord bravo pour cette présentation
moi je suis parlementaire depuis 4 mois
simplement donc je découvre un peu un
certain nombre d'éléments et j'avoue que
je suis frappé par à la fois la
diversité des outils qui sont présentés
aujourd'hui à la fois la complexité de
ces outils et je me dis qu'avec tout ça
on a finalement pas suffisamment de
résultats euh donc c'était un premier un
premier sentiment et on voit bien que en
matière de lisibilité ben on intervient
dans plein de domaines différents et je
pense qu'en en intervenant dans plein de
domaines différents plein de thématiqu
plein de ministères plein de lois
différentes je pense que certainement
ben on doit perdre d'efficacité parce
que on voit bien que les résultats
attendus neous sont pas la hauteur au
moins des engagements autre remarque
c'est un r rapport d'évaluation donc ma
question est-ce que ce rapport il existe
aussi en version financière là on est en
version intention objectif est-ce qu'il
existe la même chose de ce rapport en
version financière pour voir on regarde
l'argent investi mobiliser quels en sont
les résultats attendus donc ça c'est une
question je focalise sur la fusion de la
prime pour l'emploi et du RSA on a eu
vous avez évoqué le calendrier hein
puisque un rapport devrait être présenté
avant l'été ou courant de l'été est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui il y a des outils de
conceration qui sont mis en place euh
entre le
gouvernement les acteurs publics et
notamment les départements qui sont
aujourd'hui des acteurs quand même
privilégiés du du RSA et en même temps
est-ce que une étude d'impact financière
et aujourd'hui euh travailler mobiliser
anticiper parce que on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui on est tous dans une
volonté d'améliorer le taux
d'utilisation de ces outils sociaux mais
en même temps avec une grande
interrogation de l'incidence financière
VO mê t interrogation je crois qu'on est
incapable aujourd'hui sans une étude
poussée de pouvoir estimer ce que ça
pourrait coûter donc qui dir rformme
forcément moment dit passage au
Parlement et donc forcément j'imagine
étude d'impact financière en dans tous
les cas est-ce que vous avez des
informations dans ce volet là et je t'is
simplement par un dernier message pour
vous dire que tout ce qui concerne
l'ination par l'économie un domaine que
je connais bien
j'ai vu depuis nombreuses années
beaucoup de lois de réforme d'évolution
et à chaque fois qu'on termine la
thématique de la
simplification sur ce thème enfin sur ce
sujet là généralement ça se termine
toujours par une complexité nouvelle et
voilà donc vraiment c'est un domaine où
je pense que on pe être beaucoup plus
efficace dans le rapport entre le monde
de l'entreprise et le monde social
directement voilà je vous laisse
répondre monsieur
ch je je précise je je reste sur les les
éléments du du rapport effectivement on
pas la possibilité d'investiguer au-delà
de du du plan lui-même d'abord sur
l'hébergement logement la première vous
avez totalement raison
sur le projet de loi de finances et ce
qui est prévu pour l'hébergement qui est
inférieur à 2013 mais je suis prêt à
parier avec vous que fin 2015 vous aurez
une dépense supplémentaire 2014 c'est
comme ça depuis 20 ans et c'est comme ça
tout les ans tous les ans le budget de
cette ligne est sous-estimé et il y a
une P supplémentair l'année précédente
donc ça a pas varié cette année le
budget devrait être alimenté par les
réserves de précaution qui permettront
de de faire l'équilibre et 2000 le
budget 2014 était inférieur au au budget
2012 et il est il est sorti supérieur en
réalisé à 2013 voilà donc d'où la
remarque qu'on fait ça ne fait ça ne
fait qu'augmenter hein donc on peut pas
rester dans cette situation là et c'est
la raison pour laquelle on on fait ces
propositions sur le le les SIAO euh là
c'est la loi allure ça démarre donc
normalement il doit être remis en en
première ligne donc là les choses on
aura une évaluation alors j'ai j'ai pas
précisé dans ma présentation l'année
dernière avec le collègue avec quel j'ai
travaillé et l'adresse on a mis en place
tout un N un un une liste d'indicateurs
qui ne peuvent être enseigné que
qu'après et c'est en fonction de ces
indicateurs qu'on pourra regarder la
trème puis la 4e année comment comment
ça fonctionne sur le débat qui est posé
sur les enfants pauvres et et l'opinion
qui se durcit hein il y a il y a les
éléments et puis la question d'accès au
services que vous avez posé euh
l'opinion elle se Durc alors
paradoxalement à chaque fois qu'il y a
une crise économique l'opinion devient
plus positif sur les aides donc vous
voyez les éléments du créoc 2008 ça pas
manqué les Français sont devenus
beaucoup plus généreux mais le phénomène
qui est passé cette cette fois-ci c'est
que la pente elle est redescendue
beaucoup plus vite hein donc c'est comme
ça qui fait CREDOC dit il y a quelque
chose qui qui est qui a noté sur cet
élément même si je dirais la pente était
douce depuis pas mal de temps et petit à
petit les Français alors le discours
politique sur la stigmatisation pèse sur
les gens on peut gagner plus avec un
minima social que si on travaille ce qui
est ce qui qui a aucune démonstration
qui a été faite mais après c'est c'est
de la de la l'honnêteté des discours qui
peut qui peut faire ça je dire il y a
pas de cas où globalement
euh on peut se gagner plus donc donc ça
c'est des éléments qui nous
appartiennent pas qui mais qui qui qui
pèse dans l'opinion par contre quand
l'opinion quand les gens disent nous on
préfère les services c'est c'est de dire
on préfère
l'accompagnement on plutôt que laisser
les personnes dans une situation là et
de leur donner de l'argent on préfère
les accompagner pour qu'ils se sortent
de cette situation là c'est ça dont dont
le créoc note hein ce qui est pas
obligatoement le service public comme
vous dites mais les services publics
font partie de cet accompagnement- là et
je pense que c'est une démarche positive
que je partage moi c'est dire les
minimas sociaux sont pour aider les
personnes dans une situation difficile
mais il faut les services pour les
sortir de cette situationl et ce que
disent les Français je pense que c'est
de bon sens ne laissons pas les gens
dans les situations difficiles
faisonsles sortir de cette situationl
d'où la proposition qu'on vient de faire
sur l'accompagnement des des des
familles pauvres en particulier des
alors vous dites qu'il y a un recul les
services publics pour ce qui est de ces
services-là pour les familles pauvres
non il y a 100000 places de création de
crèche qui sont en train de se faire
réellement il y a 100000 places
d'accueil des enfants de plus de 2 ans
dans les écoles qui se font réellement
le problème c'est est-ce que les
familles qui en ont le plus besoin ces
familles-là ont accès à ces places-là et
vous savez très bien que derrière il y a
des élément de comportement et de
connaissance ou euh et bah
inévitablement les familles les plus
intéressées et puis leur réaction aussi
euh alors ce qui peut se discuter hein
euh des des gestionnaires de ces
structures y compris élus locaux qui
disent bah à partir du moment où les
gens travaillent il faut réserver ça aux
gens qui travaillent hein et et donc les
gens qui travaillent pas qui ont besoin
de de faire garder momentanément leurs
enfants pour aller chercher du travail
bah ils ont ils sont bloqués dans ce
système là donc c'est ça le débat sur
sur les services hein et ça c'est un
c'est un débat très compliqué avec
l'opinion publique mais je pense qu'il
faut essayer de de dépasser
euh alors sur les femmes seules vous
parlez d'égalité de salariale c'est un
autre débat ce débat là dedans mais
c'est un autre débat là je parle surtout
des des quand ce il s'agit de de femmes
seules qui vivent euh en dessous du
seuil de pauvreté avec leurs enfants
c'est ou des personnes qui ont pas de
travail ou des personnes qu' on des
temps tellement
partiel bien souvent en dessous des 24
heures dont on a parlé que ils ne
peuvent pas vivre de leur travail c'est
de ce sujetl hein donc ça dépasse le
problème de l'égalité salariale entre
les hommes et les femmes là c'est le
problème de l'accès à l'emploi à temps
plein hein de l'accès à l'emploi à temps
plein donc voilà le le le problème qui
est posé et donc c'est le problème de
l'accompagnement alors
euh sur l'hébergement
d'urgence vous me posez la question je
sais plus qui me posait la question de
mon sentiment sur l'hébergement
d'urgence et et sur le le logement les
MRES bâtisseurs vous posiez la question
là-dessus moi je pense qu' a le rôle de
l'État qui est qui est interrogé
là-dessus hein quand quand des
collectivités territoriales des mairies
ne respectent pas les engagements qui
doivent être CCI il faut une
substitution de l'État par rapport donc
la décision elle est là donc après c'est
ça renvoie je dirais à l'application de
la loi et est-ce que on peut se
contenter on le sait bien pour les
personnes en situation de handicap c'est
pareil hein il y a des employeurs et ils
sont ils sont nombreux qui préfèrent
payer plutôt qu'accueillir des des
personnes en situation de handicap on
est devant cette situation là
j'entendais ce matin l'échec de la loi
de de 2005 c'est pas vrai l'échec c'est
il y a une il y a une amélioration
certaine quand on fait une évaluation on
l'a vu et la situation alors le chômage
augmente pour des raisons que l'on
connaît mais mais il y a surtout non
application parce qu'on donne la
possibilité de payer plutôt de respect é
la loi et ça c'est un choix du
législateur qui qui qui nous dépasse
mais qui est qui doit être interrogé
alors après la réflexion sur la réforme
territoriale on a senti effectivement un
frein dans la dynamique bon bah qui qui
était normal mais dans la tournée qu'on
avait fait l'année dernière ce que les
professionnels de terrain et comme les
associations ont dit et souvent les élus
locaux c'est un il y a de il y a deux
complexité dans notre travail la la
complexité des niveaux d'intervention
entre les l'État peut la région en
matière sociale le département
l'intercommunalité la commune
l'association on a une logique de
guichet qui se concurrent c'est pas
coordonné entre eux avec des politiques
nationales qui viennent en tuyau d'org
et donc pour avoir un parcours
d'insertion il faut qu'on aille à tro
qure portes pour pouvoir avoir notre
notre réponse hein et et ce qui était
comment dirais-je plus réclamé c'était
pas tant de dire il faut le département
ou la commune c'est de dire il y en faut
un il faut simplifier ça et et quand le
département fait et ben si la commune
fait autre chose ou fait donc il faut
que ça soit complémentaire et c'était ça
le la grosse demande c'était ne faites
pas tous des choses qui sont qui sont
concurrentielle alors d'autres points
euh sur alors sur les rapports
financiers je on vous l'a dit hein on
n'a pas les éléments financiers du du
plan donc on na pas fait un rapport
parallèle qui est financier euh bon pour
des raisons de de de visibilité je pense
qu'il faudrait faire une enquête IGAS
IGF pour pouvoir faire un rapport
financier parce que c'est pas notre
notre cœur de métiers de la même façon
sur le r activité moi je ne sais pas le
gouvernement ce qu'il va proposer on
n'est pas associé aux travaux
préparatoires he nous on est là évuer
évaluer le le
résultat merci Madame Guidi
selli merci monsieur le Président je
voulais moi évoquer tout la les
difficultés de construire des logements
sociaux et c'est de pire en pire hein il
y a tellement de Gen difficultés et
cetera dans la ville où je vis euh la
mairie impose aux promoteurs qui veulent
pardon c'est menton la ville où elle vit
le peu importe le comment les les
promoteurs privés qui refusent de
construire des logements sociaux
euh doivent payer je je crois qu'il paye
je sais 80000 € par logement social non
non construit tout ceci étant
parfaitement légal avec la la V et ça
fait des années que ça dure avec la
valale de la préfecture et cetera ce qui
permet à la ville d'acheter des terrains
et donc ça a permis de créer pas mal de
logements sociaux comme ça il y en a un
en revanche ça fait quelques temps que
ça dur qui devait permettre de
construire sans logements sociaux plus à
côté c'était
de de l'accession à la propriété
hein ça fait 5 ans que ça dure alors
d'abord il a fallu bien sûr 2 ans pour
avoir un projet et cetera puis après
malheureusement sur le terrain a été
trouvé une fauvette à col noir alors moi
je franchement je vous assure je n'ai
rien contre les fauvettes à col noir
mais immédiatement avis défavorable du
avis défavorable du commissaire
enquêteur alors il a fallu essayer de
trouver un endroit pour mettre s'il y
avait d'autres ê à col noire et cetera
ça a duré à peu près un an un an et demi
mais après c'est un petit poisson alors
je suis navrée j'ai oublié le nom du
petit poisson mais c'était aussi pareil
et puis la dernière fois c'était il y a
un an où il y a eu des intempéries et là
le commissaire pareil a dit il faut
faire des sondages supplémentaires tout
ça coûte cher hein en plus hein faut
faire des sondages supplémentaires parce
que sans logements sociaux là c'est
maintenant selon l'état du sol vous
pourrez peut-être en faire que 60 et
cetera je trouve ça il faut en rire ou
en pleurer hein monsieur cherc c'est sûr
mais est-ce qu'on ne peut pas à un
moment aider les maires qui ont des
terrains et qui veulent construire des
logements sociaux est-ce qu'on peut
éviter de les embêter avec des fauvettes
à à col noir merci je ne fais pas exprès
mais de suite après c'est madame
archimbau je ne répondrai pas sur la
question des Fauvettes on en parlera
tout à l'heure j'aurais beaucoup à dire
mais euh Monsieur le Secrétaire monsieur
le pardon l'inspecteur général madame
merci d'être là et merci pour la la
richesse de votre de votre rapport euh
trois points d'abord concernant le non
recours au droit euh vous vous l'avez
évoqué en effet moi j'ai j'ai j'ai remis
en il y a un an et demi maintenant un
rapport au Premier ministre Jean-Marc
Erraud à la suite d'une mission
parlementaire sur le sur l'accès aux
soins en général des des personnes
démunies et j'ai j'ai j'ai fait 40
propositions dont don dont SEP de de de
simplification et au bout d'un an et
demi je je je constate qu'en
effet une mesure que je proposais qui
est simplement de de de de
connecter l'accès au droit au au RSA
socle avec l'accès au droit à la CMU
complémentaire sachant que c'est le même
plafond de
ressources et sachant que le taux de nos
recours est très important on pourra y
revenir n'est toujours pas retenu il y a
même eu chaque fois que je l'ai proposé
en amendement un avis défavorable du du
du gouvernement
euh alors qu'en fait on le sait alors
vous l'avez évoqué également il n'y a
pas de si j'ai bien compris il n'y a pas
de chiffrage récent du N recours au
droit on parle bien des droits qui sont
dans la loi hein je parle pas plus
généralement d'accès à des droits
sociaux je parle de ce qui est inscrit
dans la loi du point de vue d'un point
de vue républicain c'est c'est c'est
très choquant et je je je pense que ça
contribue tout à fait à à la perte de
repèr républicain dans l'opinion
publique quand vous avez parce que moi
c'est les chiffres que j'ai qui sont les
chiffres de l'INC quand vous avez 30 %
des bénéficiaires du RSA socle qui n'ont
pas pu faire aboutir leur dossierers CMU
complémentaire en Île-de-France le
chiffre avancé est même de 40 %. euh
quand vous avez toujours moi j'ai
toujours les chiffres qui étaient
avancés par le Premier ministre en 2013
he entre 10 à 24 % de gens en France qui
n'ont pas pu faire ouvrir leur droit à
la smue complémentaire alors qu'ils ont
droit pourquoi est-ce qu'on n pas euh
cette mesure de de de simplification
vous vous avez souligné vous-même que ça
posait ça posait problème et euh alors
on avance des arguments financiers mais
ce sont des arguments financiers à très
court terme d'abord encore une fois d'un
point de vue républicain je pense que si
on peut pas si les gens sentent que
alors qu'ils ont des droits ces droits
sont sont en fait euh il n'arrive pas
dans les faites à y accéder ça ça ça
brouille les pistes ça explique beaucoup
de choses et et beaucoup de choses aussi
dans la montée des extrémisme mais d'un
point de vue financier pourquoi comment
expliquez-vous que l'étude qui a été
faite par le sgmap qui a été rendu publ
en octobre
2013 qui qui est une étude très sérieuse
faite gmap qui est pilotée directement
par les service du Premier
ministre le titre de l'étude c'est
gisement moins de maladie moins de
maladie dit et cette étude très sérieuse
montre que en comparant des familles qui
ont accès à la CMU complémentaire donc
au tiers payant euh ne payent pas les
franchises et forfait hospitaliers
beaucoup plus intéressants ces
personnes comparé à un autre contingent
de personnes qui n'ont pas pu ouvrir
leur droit à la cmucé au bout d'un an
elles sont moins malades c'est un fait
elles sont moins malade donc il y a une
économie qui est qui est qui est
chiffrée dans cette étude d'un peu une
économie c'est-à-dire moins de frais
médicaux hein de plus de 400 € par an
par rapport à ce que coûte entre
guillemets l'attribution de la CMU
complémentaire donc donc notre pays les
les les comptes sociaux là-dessus ont
fait des économies donc
financièrement
financièrement il est faux il est
objectivement faux de dire que l'accès
au
droit pose un problème financier
euh tous les médecins diront par
ailleurs que c'est c'est que c'est à
très à très court terme parce
qu'évidemment les gens ne se soignent
pas donc quand ils vont aux urgences de
ou 3 ans plus tard ets sont très malades
et que ça coûte beaucoup plus cher
comment arriver à à à obtenir ça alors
avez-vous vous des renseignements euh
sur la poursuite du travail du SG map
est-ce qu'il va pouvoir parce que je
sais qu'ils ont prévu des des
expérimentations mais apparemment ces
expérimentation ne se poursuivent pas et
je pense que c'est c'est dommage euh
d'autre part euh un mot sur les jeunes
j'ai j'ai j'ai en effet pu constater euh
dans le territoire que je connais
particulièrement la sens Sani en
discutant avec des jeunes qui ont accès
à la garantie jeune que c'est un
dispositif très très intéressant très
euh qui qui fonctionne qui est exigeant
vis-à-vis des jeunes mais qui fonctionne
et mais on voit très bien que euh il
manque par exemple la question de
traitement la question du logement pour
les jeunes parce que ces mêmes jeunes
qui viennent dans les missions locales
et qui suivent le dispositif garant
antijeunes qui sont là tous les jours et
cetera sur un certain nombre de ces
jeunes qui étaient présents quand j'ai
quand je les ai rencontré certains sont
SDF donc ils viennent tous les jours à
Mission locale avec leurs affaires ils
logent à ils sont à la rue donc
ilchaînent les hébergements qu'on
imagine mais vous connaissez vous
connaissez la situation enfin
dernièrement ne pensez-vous pas qu'il
serait intéressant
aussi de poursuivre sur le plan
financier et de voir de de de calculer
combien coûte le non recours
financièrement
monsieur
Forissier oui merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur l'Inspecteur
Général votre rapport est un rapport qui
est compréhensible qui est précis et
vous avez parfaitement raison de mettre
un le point de mettre un focus sur
l'inclusion sociale des plus jeunes dans
notre société parce qu'effectivement
étant mère d'une commune l'agglomération
lyonnaise ayant exercé des
responsabilités dans un
département importante puisque j'ai été
jusqu'à le présidé par intérim en tant
que premier vice-président et maintenant
étant dans une métropole en construction
on se rend compte quand même qu'on est
au milieu de beaucoup d'incohérence
parce qu'on a passe on passe
actuellement beaucoup de temps à essayer
de voir comment on va s'organiser au
niveau territorial dans l'avenir n'ayant
aucune certitude sur les orientations
qui seront retenues en débat permanent
moi je pense que certains de mes
collègues ont mis en avant que la clause
de compétence générale était sans doute
à supprimer à certaines collectivités
parce que évidemment si tout le monde
fait tout et n'importe quoi au bout d'un
moment il y a une dispersion de l'argent
public moi je voudrais mettre l'accent
sur deux sujets l'inclusion sociale
parce par deux facteurs principaux qui
sont le travail et le
logement je fais partie de ceux qui ont
fait fait tro fois et demi leurs
objectifs en logements sociaux une
commune de 30000 habitants qui prend en
gros 5 à 600 habitants par an qui va en
prendre 1000 de plus dans les 4 5 ans à
venir c'est-à-dire qu'en 10 ans on va
prendre 10000 habitants aujourd'hui on a
pu
accompagner le quartier en politique de
la ville comme beaucoup de villes on a
pu accompagner l'équipement et servic
publics parce que les communes avaient
des marges de manœuvre aujourd'hui quand
on regarde sur l'avenir parce que le
rétroviseur Mo ça va bien 5 minutes mais
sur l'avenir on se rend compte que les
collectivités n'ont plus les moyens
d'accompagner avec l'équipement public
et les services publics suffisants donc
c'est là aujourd'hui moi je pense qu'il
y a une incohérence et je voudrais votre
avis là-dessus sur la politique de la
ville on considère qu'avoir fait du
renouvellement urbain c'est terminé et
on abandonne les quartiers alors que
l'humain il faut l'accompagner et
continuer et ça aujourd'hui euh c'est un
peu ce déficit dans les politiques
nationales qui je crois sont à revoir
c'est l'accompagnement humain parce que
je veux bien qu'on préfigure tous les
plans qu'on voudra mais si on n'a fait
pas des choix politiques d'orientation
budgétaire dans le sens d'augmentation
budgétaire quitte à à faire des coupes
ailleurs hein mais je crois que
gouverner c'est choisir et aujourd'hui
cette orientation elle est n nécessaire
compte tenu de ce qu'on connaît tous
dans nos banlieux je vous remercie
madame Emer Duma
oui monsieur le Président merci Monsieur
cherk Je je voulais vous poser quelques
questions par rapport à à cette
présentation qui était tout à fait tout
à fait intéressante une première
question par rapport à la mission qui
qui vous est confiée donc la mission
d'évaluation du du plan j'ai bien
compris que c'était une mission
d'évaluation de ce que le plan mettait
en œuvre et de la manière dont il était
mis en œuvre euh j'aurais voulu savoir
si votre mission s'étendait aussi à
l'évolu à l'évaluation de de
l'efficience du plan c'est-à-dire à à
l'évolution de la pauvreté et des des
critères permettant de de la chiffrer
sur les sur les territoires et cette
première question m'amène à vous
soulever aussi la la question de la
dimension territoriale de l'évolution de
la de la pauvreté à mettre ça en regard
des travaux qui ont été menés not
notamment dans le cadre de
l'hyperruralité par notre collègue Alain
Bertrand qui a permis de de montrer
carte à l'appui une évolution de de la
pauvreté et de la grande pauvreté vers
des territoires ruraux et hyper ruraux
et ce qui m'amène à la question qui qui
a trait au aux conclusions de de votre
mission d'évaluation pour cette année et
la proposition de mettre en place un un
plan d'aide pour les familles pauvres et
je me pose des questions quand à la
manière dont vous envisagez de prendre
en compte cette dimension de
l'hyperruralité dans la mise en œuvre
des de l'aide au famille pauvre parce
que je crois que les les les les moyens
d'action et les et les possibilités de
de service auxquels vous faites
référence ne sont pas toujours
disponibles sur ces territoires là
madame génissant
oui je vais je vais être dans la
continuité de l'interpellation de ma
collègue Monsieur l'Inspecteur Général
pour vous poser la question particul
des chefs de famille monoparental c'est
c'est-à-dire du sujet des femmes sur
deux questions primordiales la garde
d'enfants et la mobilité est-ce que vous
avez des des chiffres particuliers à
nous fournir est-ce que vous avez des
propositions intéressantes qui sort des
chemins battus également qui pourrait
être mise en place voà monsieur ch je
vous laisse
répondre
alors sur tout ce qui est code de
l'urbanisme je reviendrai pas sur ce ce
problème là l'organisation que c'est
tellement compliqué et toutes les
complexités administratives pour
construire du logement au-delà des des
contingence écologiqu euh bon voilà
c'est c'est pas notre c'était pas notre
sujet même si même si ils existent sur
le N recours l'accès au droit alors vous
avez vu madame archambau on a fait cette
proposition que vous avez mis dans votre
rapport d'accès automatique de à la CMUC
alors vous vous dites
euh problème financier oui je je je
pense même si c'est pas dit que si c'est
pas réglé depuis le temps c'est que
globalement c'est bien alors le non
accès au droit qui avait été chiffré par
l'Observatoire national de la pauvreté
de l'exclusion sociale avait chiffré en
2013 6 milliards d'euros le non accès au
droit par rapport à ce que vous dites le
coûte ce qui c'est pas le coûte c'est
c'est le non dépensé quoi en fait hein
hein c'est l'économie si vousoulez vous
le dites comme vous voulez mais il y a 6
milliards d'euros de droits non utilisés
non consommés par par la population ce
qui ce qui casse un petit peu le le
l'image de de personnes qui vent avec
des m sociaux et qui courent après
visiblement il y a une partie de la
population qui qui court pas après alors
ça va de de non accès au droit 30 % pour
ce qui est de RSA activité jusqu'à 30 %
à peu près pour la la CMUC pour les gens
qui ont le RSA le le pour le oui c'est
ce que je disais alors moi je pense la
seule façon de faire la seule façon de
faire c'est puisqu'on a le diagnostic il
est clair les coûtes sont clairs euh
c'est de dire on fait un plan d'accès au
droit et on le chiffre et on l'intègre
dans le budget de la protection sociale
autrement on y arrivera pas parce
qu'autrement on est sur des plans
d'accès au droit dont on n'est pas en
capacité de dire qu'est-ce qu'ils vont
produire et qu'est-ce que ça va donner
en terme financier donc inévitablement
et bah on voit bien qu'on est sur des
enveloppes fermées et on y va pas vraim
la seule façon de de faire c'est de dire
voilà on est à je sais pas tel minima
social ou à accès à la à la protection
sociale on est à 60 % et ben sur 3 ans
on passe de 60 % à 90 % et on le chiffre
et on l'intègre dans le dans autrement
on n arrivera pas voilà alors derrière
on avait fait la demande avec mon
collègue l'année dernière sur le premier
rapport qu'on chiffre le coût différé de
non acccès au droit hein et ça euh on a
souhaité que là aussi c'est une décision
de demander à l'adresse en lien avec
d'autres laboratoires de faire une étude
du coût différés et en terme d'accès à
la santé c'est évident en terme d'accès
à la santé c'est évident d'ailleurs le
le fond CMU le fond CMU qui fait des
statistique on a le débat sur le tiers
payant actuellement ils disent quand les
gens ont accès à la CBU il y a des
dépenses supplémentaires évidentes la
première année mais qui baisse et qui
s'atténu les autres années euh tout ce
qui est lunettes d inévitablement vous
avez accès à un droit vous vous achetez
des lunettes vous faites mettre des
lunettes vous soignez vos dents et puis
l'année d'après euh inévitablement
donc on a le droit à de s'interroger sur
la coordination de ces plans
l'efficacité de ces plans c'est-à-dire
que vous avez des plans pour les les
personnes qui vivent seules l'accès à
l'emploi de ces personnesl du logement
pour ces
personneslà de de politique de la ville
de la jeunesse et donc et une femme
seule avec ses enfants dans un quartier
politique de la ville c'est celle qui
est plus pauvre donc il y a quand même
quelque chose qui va pas quoi je je je
je pense et ça c'est une interrogation
globale de notre système de protection
sociale et d'aide qui
qui de la coordination de de de toute
cette complexité donc voilà c'est la
seule remarque que je fais et
que bah il y a pas de coordination mais
il y a un élément je termine sur l'autre
question sur les territoires ruraux
pareil dans notre rapport l'année
dernière on a dit on sait ce que c'est
que les quartiers politiques de la ville
on n'a pas défini dans les politiques ou
quasiment pas ce que c'est que les
territoires ruraux isolés pauvres donc
on a à reprendre en particulier sur le
phénomène que vous dites mais quand nous
on fait des propositions sur les
familles pauvres c'est pas que les
familles pauvres dans les quartiers
politiques de la ville hein c'est clair
et et quand j'ai fait ce Tour de France
l'INC est capable de nous dire sur des
carrés 200 m sur des carrés taux de
pauvreté et je prends des des des
exemple j'ai vu en PACA le taux de
pauvreté le département le plus pauvre
c'est le département des plus rural
c'est le vcluse le bas des abdau de
Provence et et et
l'ouestén non mais qu'est-ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que globalement on a
des quartiers
au nord de Marseille mais on a des zones
rurales encore plus pauvres donc donc
globalement il faut adapter ces
politiques effectivement à cette
nouvelle carte qui sont des des
territoires urbains comme on dit et et
donc voilà après sur vos deux questions
sur les gardes d'enfants sur les gardes
d'enfants c'est l'application de ce qui
est prévu dans le plan c'est globalement
est-ce qu'on a cap les solutions
innovantes ont été testé dans certaines
dans certaines communes hein Grenoble a
fait l'île a fait il y a des communes
qui ont fait avec avec des Nantes aussi
qu'on a on a vu Nantes le département de
la Loire Atlantique c'est globalement
c'est l'accès de ces enfants là aux
structures collective et en organisant
aussi pour les classes moyennes parce
que évidemment il est pas question
d'exclure certains de des gardes donc
c'est une de prise en charge globale et
et cet accès est fondamental sur
l'apprentissage de la de de de de
l'expression de la vie collective et
cetera et cetera après sur la mobilité
on a fait on a fait la remarque il y
avait normalement des études sur la
mobilité des travailleurs pauvres qui
ont pas été faites donc je pense qu'il
faut les
reprendre bien on va continuer je
répondrai sur le vooccluse après mais je
surtout pas le président du conseil
général était là il est parti mais on
pourra revenir dessus madame
gruni madame grunier est partie pard
excuse-moi c'est pas grave j'allais
poser une question sur sur la fin
programmé des départements donc si j'ai
bien compris ça ça ne vous inquiète pas
à partir du moment où finalement on a
plus de de simplification en matière de
de guichet et où où on garde la
proximité au niveau des communes ou des
de l'intercommunalité voilà euh sur sur
les gardes d'enfants en fait moi j'ai
une association des mamans solo leur
difficultés parce qu'elles aimeraient
travailler mais elles ne peuvent prendre
que des des contrats temps partiel et
très partiels parce que elles ont des
enfants qui sont au collège avec des
sorties de collège à 15h 16h et donc ils
sont dans la rue les les les gamins ou
chez eux mais ils restent pas chez eux
et donc derrière de la délinquence et
vraiment des grosses difficultés dans la
parentalité et ensuite sur sur le
financement euh des des jeunes il y a un
un nouveau Fond Européen destination des
jeunes qui a été mis en place fin 2013
he initiative pour emploi des jeunes 6
milliards d'euros pour l'Union
européenne mais qui a priori n'est pas
tellement mobilisé au niveau de la de la
France
voilà Monsieur cadiic
oui
merci oui je voulais vraiment remercier
pour cette présentation je suis assez
fasciné par l'étendue du du plan et ça
son côté humaniste qui je
pense touche beaucoup de gens ceci étant
dit j'ai quand même beaucoup de mal
évaluer l'impact de ce de ces mesures
sur le taux de pauvreté et là je
voudrais un peu compléter donc les les
commentaires de mon collègue Philippe
mouill qui a qui l'a présenté sous
l'angle de la version
financière donc j'ai bien compris que
vous n'aviez pas d'élément financiers
pour pour venir étayer ce plan pour
l'instant ceci étant du coup moi je
voudrais me focaliser sur le côté
indicateur donc
objectif puisque le concept du plan de
pauvreté je pense que c'est l' objectif
c'est bien de faire baisser ce taux de
pauvreté donc je voudrais savoir si vous
avez des exemples de pays qui ont eu des
résultat sur le taux de pauvreté pour
faire baisser ce taux de pauvreté pour
justifier l'efficience des mesures qui
sont proposé dans le dans le plan quel
est l'objectif du taux de pauvreté à
2017 euh pour la France grâce à ce plan
et donc quel serait notre classement
dans l'Union européenne à 2017 et quel
est-il à ce jour pour pouvoir nous
permettre de nous évaluer par rapport
aux opé de l'Union merci Madame
Ambert merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur l'Inspecteur général oui merci
également pour cette présentation fort
intéressante et pour le Tour de France
que vous avez fait l'année dernière
puisque j'avais participé moi-même au
travaux région poitoucharante et j'avais
apprécié vos vos interventions néanmoins
de deux questions euh sur la politique
famille et enfance vous évoquez un point
de vigilance sur le le développement
d'action en faveur des sortants de de
l'Aide Sociale à l'Enfance et des
mineurs isolés étrangers vous savez que
les départements accueillent de plus en
plus ces jeunes mineurs isolés étrangers
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire plus
sur ce développement d'action
puisqueaujourd'hui nous avons du mal
comp tenu de leur nombre qui augmente
dans nos départements à les accompagner
à leur proposer des des projets de vie
pertinents notamment du mal à avoir des
des des propositions constructives avec
l'Éducation nationale euh deuxème
question qui concerne
le logement
euh je voudrais avoir votre avis et si
vous partagez le mien en tout cas sur
les effets pervers des des logements
basse consommation construit en en zone
tendue puisque les bailleurs sociaux du
coup constatent un surcout à la
construction donc demande un surloyer et
on arrive à une contradiction
complètement aberrente dire que la
personne isolée bénéficiaire du RSA ne
peut plus rentrer dans ces dans ces
logements et et en fait on leur fait
payer des économies d'énergie euh avant
même qu'ils aient pu les faire quoi
merci beaucoup madame caniller oui merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur
l'Inspecteur Général moi je voulais
juste revenir sur la la garantie jeune
parce que il savère je suis présidente
d'une mission locale qui met en place la
garantie jeune de manière dans la
deuxème phase d'expérimentation et que
donc nous avons 500 jeunes accompagn
durant cette année je pense que c'est un
bon dispositif qui permet effectivement
une prise en charge globale et nous on a
travaillé conventionné avec la ville
pour mettre en place des des mettre à
disposition des places de crèche pour
les jeunes filles qui sont dans la G
anti-jeune en situation de
monoparentalité on convionne aussi avec
les bailleurs pour des logements bon
pour vraiment prendre l'accompagnement
global la difficulté aujourd'hui c'est
qu'on a un peu une concurrence entre
enfin une concurrence au moins une un
doublon entre la garantie jeune et l'IEJ
qui arrive en même temps et qui sont mis
en œuvre par nos conseillers vis-à-vis
des parfois des mêmes jeunes ce qui crée
un peu d'opacité ça c'est une première
chose et deuxième chose c'est que on
voit que c'est l'accompagnement global
qui qui qui faut fonctionne et c'est
l'intérêt de cette garantie jeune par
contre c'est vrai que pour les familles
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
aujourd'hui pour nous parce que sur
notamment ces familles pauvre on voit
qu'on a énormément de dispositifs
énormément d'acteurs et que souvent il y
a des doublons et que ce qui est fait
d'un côté la réussite par la réussite
éducative par exemple va être aussi mis
en place par les conseillers de la du
CCAS peut être mis en place aussi par
les les conseillers des bailleurs
sociaux enfin on voit qu'on a énormément
de d'opacité et d'intervenants diff
auprès de ses familles ça c'est une
première chose et la deuxième sujet
c'était concernant le le logement je
rejoins ce que vient de dire ma ma
collègue Corine Amber nous on a eu un
grand plan de renouvellement urbain
beaucoup de construction de logement
neufs mais qui sortent à des des loyers
à des taux de loyers qui sont
inaccessible par nos familles pauvres et
par contre c'est vrai que on a un parc
social existant qui est très vétuste et
pas vraiment remis aux normes renouvelé
au malheureusement et Monsieur le moine
qui est le dernier inscrit pour
l'instant merci président
euh une une remarque une question la
remarque c'est pour aller dans le
droitfil de de ma collègue Anne h Duma
Emer Duma euh je constate également une
une très grande croissance enfin d'une
certaine précarisation au milieu rural
et très rural et qui souvent en fait
comment dire le nœud du problème est
également lié à la mobilité euh et et le
problème euh c'est très bê enfin moi je
prends régulièrement des gens en stop et
donc quand j'interroge qu'est-ce qui se
passe bon bah c'est le moteur de la R21
KT on a plus les moyens de de racheter
un véhicule et cetera et le problème
c'est que les associations qui parfois
auparavant étaient là euh type mobilecho
pour fournir prêter des véhicules sont
elles-même de plus en plus en difficulté
on n'est pas sûr de maintenir le
maillage qui existe à l'URE actuel sur
le territoire et donc c'est vrai que moi
je je tire un peu la sonette d'alarme
sur les milieux ruraux et très ruraux
parce que je je vois pas
de comment dire je vois pas de de
d'amélioration des des des du du du de
la situation du tissu associatif
permettant
d'accompagner ces personnes-là donc qui
sont gênés par par des problèmes de
mobilité ça c'était la remarque la
question c'était j'ai vu donc les
chiffres euh macro par rapport à à la au
nombre de personnes qui effectivement
sont sous le seuil de pauvreté VI de
pauvreté est-ce que on a des indicateurs
par rapport à leur au fait que il y a
parmi elles des personnes qui
travaillent et qui effectivement même si
elles sont à temps partiel ou très
partiel du coup continuent à rester sous
ces ce chiffre indicateur et et comment
ça évolue en dynamique est-ce que il y a
de moins en moins de travailleurs pauvre
ou bien malheureusement est-ce que ça ça
s'accroit merci Monsieur ch
oui
alors sur le débat sur le les
départements sur la proximité et qu' la
la
remarque moi je pense que le le le plan
sur ce sujetl c'était construit à partir
d'un rapport qui a été fait par Michel
dîny qui était le le président du
conseil général de Meurth etemosel sur
l'organisation territoriale et qui avait
amené une vraie dynamique sur ce
sujet-là en particulier et c'est ça qui
a amené cette opération qu'il appellent
agile qui était sur la simplification
des d'organisation des schémas
territoriaux et tout ce qui est
comitologie et autres réunions instances
départementales euh je pense que cette
démarche là elle a elle a de l'avenir le
le principe étant que celui qui est le
porteur de je dirais de qui est le chef
de file sur un thème passe des des des
éléments de contrat et d'organisation
avec ceux qui qui font un complé
donc c'est expérimentation qui a
travaillé pendant un an Michel d a
beaucoup participé bah inévitablement
avec le débat sur la fin des des
départements c'est parti un petit peu
dans tous les sens maintenant c'est
repris et il y a des départements qui
reviennent donc moi j'ai plutôt espoir
maintenant que les choses sont un peu
près éclairci que que que qu'on puisse
revenir cet élément là parce que le
débat était pas uniquement sur la
compétence générale c'était surtout la
le débat sur la coordination des
compétences des des différents et
comment on fait pas je dirais et qu'on
fait pas en plus de ce que fait le
voisin donc voilà ça c'était un élément
important sur ce sujet-là après sur ce
qui est dit sur la garde périscolaire la
parentalité moi je partage tout à fait
ce sujetl alors le le 20 janvier il y a
une circulaire qui est partie au préfet
pour normalement il doit y avoir un
schéma de la petite en France de la
parentalité qui est mis en place dans
tous les départements mais là aussi on
est dans la complexité hein il y a le
rôle de l'État il y a le rôle des
communes il y a le rôle des départements
euh c'est que globalement qui est le
chef de fil sur il y a les rôles de
l'éducation nationale euh il y a il y a
il y a tout ça et et globalement euh
personne ne veut prendre le donc il va
falloir décider qui c'est qui décide
quoi en gros hein et là chacun attend
que le voisin fasse et et là il y a un
problème vous avez vous avez bien raison
alors il y a le rôle des des communes
hein sur les mais bon voilà donc je vais
pas plus loin mais il faut il va falloir
voir comment euh ce travail des schémas
territoriaux se met en place euh sur la
parentalité est-ce que c'est vraiment en
place et qu'est-ce qu'ils vont donner
hein alors sous le Fond Européen de la
jeunesse la France est le premier pays
qui a fait son son projet donc je je
partage pas l'idée que la France en
retard c'est le premier pays qui a fait
son projet le la garantie jeune est
financée en grande partie par le Fond
Européen de la
jeunesse dans mon budget puisque je suis
président de l'agence de service civique
qui a 18 millions d'euros qui est prévu
du Fond Européen de la jeunesse pour les
jeunes qui sont sur ces territoire là le
problème de la mise en œuvre et là je le
vois bien pour pour ce Tru du Fond
Européen de la le Gest c'est l'extrême
complexité des dossiers à monter donc
voilà je là on parle de simplification
là je me rends compte directement que
j'ai j'ai à géré un budget national que
je me je me gratte la tête quand même
pour y arriver hein c'est-à-dire que il
faut il faut quasiment qu'on crée qu'on
crée des des effectifs pour gérer un
fond quoi là c'est très très compliqué
mais vous connaissez ça hein et
maintenant il y a la nouvelle
répartition qui est la répartition
territoriale où effectivement il peut y
avoir certains certains endroits où des
initiatives se croisent et comm on peut
pas avoir le financement deux fois de
l'Europe sur la même
initiative mais pour la garantie jeune
il y a un financement fléché là-dessus
et qui euh alors c'est vrai que
l'émission local Râ parce que c'est
compliqué
euh alors sur les indicateurs d'impact
on a mis en place vous vous verrez dans
l'index du rapport il y a il y a une
centaine de pages d'indicateurs donc on
a mis en place avec l'adresse tout un
tas d'indicateurs pour suivre les effets
quasiment mesur par mesure hein mais ils
sont ils sont quasiment pas renseignés
encore parce que on va voir les des
chiffres 2013 donc on a un suivi réel de
de ces éléments de de pauvreté d'une
part mais aussi l'effet sur bah l'accès
au logement sur les fait sur dalallau on
a mis des indicateurs comme ça qui sont
assez précis et on a obtenu cette année
de l'adresse à fait clinc ils vont être
territorialisés donc à partir de l'année
prochaine chaque région va reproduire
les mêmes indicateurs dans les régions
donc là on aura une visibilité de la
mise en œuvre du plan euh moi le souhait
que j'ai c'est que ça dépasse le plan
c'est-à-dire que que que tout ça soit
suivi dans le temps hein je je pense que
là il y a un gros travail des des
structures statistiques là-dessus alors
les objectifs la France 2017 ils sont
pas donnés ils sont pas donnés hein il y
a quand même un problème vis-à-vis de
l'Europe normalement la France doit
présenter un rapport sur la pauvreté et
ses mesures à l'Europe et et là le
gouvernement s'est un peu contenté du
plan donc peut-être il il y a un
problème là-dessus euh mais le Tau
pauvreté il faut faire attention du taux
de pauvreté hein la Grande-Bretagne a
son taux de pauvreté qui descend tous
les ans mais pour une raison simple
c'est que son salaire médian descend
tous les ans donc de fait on peut avoir
une diminution du taux de pauvreté sans
qu'il y a enrichissement des personnes
qui sortent du de pauvreté et et la
France a eu un taux de pauvreté en 2012
qui baissait de 01 % tout simplement
parce que le salaire médian est baissé
de 0,5 donc de fait en un effet
mécanique en a moins de pauvre
statistiquement mais ce qui veut pas
dire que leur situation en condition de
vie et c'est amélioré he vous comprenez
bien que ça il y a c'est les limites des
statistiques sur les mineurs étrangers
j'ai pas grand chose à vous dire si ce
n'est que euh le le Conseil d'État vient
d'valider une partie de la la circulaire
de Madame tobira et demande au
gouvernement de voir avec le Parlement
le problème de la répartition des
mineurs sur les territoires hein donc
c'est c'est c'est le seul sujet que que
j'ai de de nouveau par contre sur ce que
vous dites vous deux êtes intervenu
là-dessus sur le problème de des des
logements sociaux qui sont rénovés avec
un surloyer on l'a cité dans notre
rapport l'année dernière il y a il y a
quand même quelque chose de qui qui qui
va pas quoi il y a c'est là là c'est
c'est comme vous dites contreproductif
et donc voilà donc normalement dans le
plan il y a un engagement du
gouvernement de d'une augmentation de
construction de logements sociaux mais
très sociaux mais ce qui veut pas dire
vu le nombre qui seront réduit qui
seront répartis sur le territoire et et
ça pose le problème de de ce que vous ce
que vous dites et je termine sur euh la
situation en milieu rural qui était cité
la la dernière intervention je sais plus
qui qui c'était euh dans les rapports
l'année dernière on a fait toute une
partie là-dessus je répète ce que j'ai
dit tout à l'heure c'est vrai qu'il y a
je dirais un surhandicap pour les
personnes isolées pauvres en milieu
rural pour des raisons de déplacement
d'accès au droit des autres comme ça
alors moi moi il y a une idée hein en
particulier sur l'accès au droit pas
pour le pas pour l'emploi mais pour
l'accès au droit euh je sais que la
Poste réfléchit sur les maisons de
service publics pour utiliser leurs
17000 contacts pour faire des maisons de
service public il y a la réflexion sur
le simulateur des droits et qui est mis
en place si on mettait déjà dans tous
les points de contact de la Poste des
simulateurs des droits pour que les
personnes de proximité puisque 17000
points contact c'est quand même pas mal
encore sur le territoire hein c'est la
seule structure publique qui a ça tant
au milieu rural qu'en milieu urbain ça
permettrait déjà d'avoir des
renseignements d'accès au droit et comme
je suis Pr président de l'agence de
service civique s'il y a des gens qui
ont du mal à rentrer leord donner on
pourrait mettre des jeunes en service
civique qui aideent les personnes à
avoir accès à l'informatique un
renseignement 17000 points un jeunes par
par point de contact vous voyez le
nombre de jeunes en service CIVI donc je
j'en profite pour promouvoir un autre
programme que je dois promouvoir mais on
voit qu'il y a des il y a des actions
qui sont pas de la substitution l'emploi
on peut pas mettre une assistante
sociale derrière chaque ordinateur mais
un je dans Service Civique ça serait
peut-être utile de le faire et ça
pourrait améliorer c'est pas la solution
pour les zones rurales hein je je je le
dis bien mais là on a un problème de de
moi je pense qu'il faut qu'on qu'on
réfléchisse sur ces programmes en en
zone rurale isolé le Premier ministre
dans sa première lettre de mission me
dit vous aurez une attention
particulière sur les zones rurales
isolées mais je sais pas ce que c'est
qu'une zone rurale isolé en terme de
politique publique donc il faut il faut
y
travailler je je précise que j'étais
secrétaire départemental de l'Union
départemental les abdau de Provence donc
les zones rural isolé je connais un
petit peu quand même bien je pense qu'on
a pas d aborder tous les sujets puisque
madame Gatel souhaite vous poser une
question merci monsieur le Président
merci de cette présentation euh j'ai
deux points qui seront très brevs le
premier je voudrais insister sur ce qu'a
dit mon collègue sur ce que en campagne
on appelle la misère et non pas la
pauvreté et que vous disiez tout à
l'heure que on constate que les certains
Français sont parfois excédés parce
qu'ils
appel de l'assistance moi je pense qu'on
voit bien émerger dans notre pays les
derniersres résultats aux élections le
montre une une vraie misère et en tout
cas une désespérance dans les campagnes
qui est difficile qui est très difficile
à traiter vous l'avez dit mais je pense
qu'il faut qu'on soit extrêmement
vigilant parce que au-delà de la misère
dans les campagne il y a aussi un
isolement qui est à la fois lié au
manque de mobilité mais aussi un
isolement moral parce qu'il y a parfois
une certaine forme de H et puis le
deuxième point concerne le logement
social donc j'approuve tout ce qui a été
dit par mes collègu mais je voudrais
revenir sur un point dont on se refuse
régulièrement à aborder c'est celui de
la mobilité à l'intérieur du parc social
donc moi j'ai bien compris que il
fallait garder dans le parc social des
personnes qui pourraient en sortir et
qui payent un surloyer mais parce que ça
peut garantir la pérennité financière
des bailleurs sociaux et que surtout ça
fait de la mixité sociale qu'on a du mal
à faire mais quand même moi dans ma
commune je pourrais construire sans
arrêt des logements sociaux ce que
j'essaie de faire mais il n en aurait
jamais assez car je constate que par
exemple là où il y avait une famille de
deux parents avec deux ou trois enfants
les enfants sont partis il reste plus
parfois qu'un des deux conjoints et
cette personne elle reste dans le T4 ou
dans le T5 qu'elle avait et que moi je
pense que si le logement social il est
fait pour aider les personnes et on doit
tous contribuer à cette solidarité on
sait que le logement c'est important on
devrait aussi pouvoir encourager
faciliter voir être un peu plus
incitatif sur la mobilité à l'intérieur
et ajuster la taille de l'appartement à
la situation de à la situation de la
personne ça c'est une vraie question moi
j'aimerais bien qu'on regarde avec sans
trop de de de pudeur et sans caricature
une question sur laquelle on reviendra
d'ailleurs dans le cadre de la loi sur
le
vieillissement je peux caler dans dans
le même sens avez
raison donc voil cétait remar REM tout à
fait bien chers collègues merci Monsieur
merci
madame je pense que nous avons fait un
peu le tour de de ce sujet nous vous
remercions et vous
libérons voilà pour cette audition sur
le thème de la lutte contre la pauvreté
la commission des affaires sociales
auditionné François cherrek et Christina
abrosimov les auteurs d'un rapport pour
l'inspection général des affaires
sociales Ligas publié en janvier dernier
à ce sujet un rapport qui s'inscrit dans
le cadre d'un vaste plan pluriannuel de
lutte contre la pauvreté lancé en
janvier 2013 parmi les pistes évoquées
par les auteurs et bien un plan de lutte
pour préserver les familles pauvres et
également la fusion entre le RSA
activité et la prime pour l'emploi pour
favoriser l'accès à ce droit pour les
personnes concernées enfin les auteurs
du rapport préconisent et bien une vaste
réunion dès le début de cette année avec
tous les acteurs concernés par la lutte
contre la pauvreté vous pouvez toujours
voir et revoir toutes les auditions sur
notre site publicsena.fr quant à moi je
vous retrouve à 16h30 pour le débat sur
la transition énergétique dans
l'hémicycle très bonne journée à vous
sur les chaînes
parlementaires